i just don't think my story ends here
i just don't know how to get out of it
all right holly
hi holly where did you grow up where are
you from originally um i'm from
gloucester massachusetts um i'm
the oldest i have a younger brother and
two younger sisters
um my dad was is an alcoholic um my mom
is an addict
um
[Music]
you know i i grew up
you know kind of rough i had to grow up
real early you know
i had a child at 16
and was on my own at 17 um not much help
from his father as far as child support
is concerned what was your childhood
like
my childhood was uh
it was it was rough you know
um my dad was real nasty when he drank
um
you know in in
you know sometimes he would mistake me
for my mom
you know uh i remember when i was eight
years old and
um well i think maybe it was ten but we
were at a family cookout and
um
you know we were all having a good time
and everybody's you know playing and
then i noticed my dad's sitting at the
at the picnic table and
he was kind of nodding out and i was
concerned so i went over to him and he
kept calling me by my mom's name which
is nancy i said no i'm not i'm not nancy
i'm your daughter you know and he asked
me took me to ask me to go with him to
his truck to get something
and i said well why don't we go get mom
but he wasn't
he uh
just wasn't he was convinced i was my
mom so i went out to the truck with him
and
um we sat out there for a good two hours
well at 10 years old like he had a
nine millimeter in his glove compartment
and
he uh
he wanted to
kill himself because he thought he was a
bad father a bad husband but he also
wanted to kill me too because he thought
it was my mom and if he couldn't have
her nobody could
and uh
so it you know that age i had to
calm him down
in in
enough so that he wouldn't kill us both
um and it was almost two hours we sat in
that truck before someone actually
noticed that we were missing
and uh my cousin georgie actually
uh had showed up and he saw the look on
my face and
the gun in my father's lap and and the
keys were in the ignition and
you know caught called for help and
the next thing i know someone's opening
the passenger door of the truck and
um
you know being yanked out of the car out
of the trap and it was a you know it's a
real big issue
um i just couldn't understand like
why it took two hours for somebody to
notice that we were missing or nobody
noticed that he was so inebriated like
you know
nobody noticed
but
um
and you got pregnant at 16 yes i did uh
i did i was um
young and just having fun you know it's
a summer time
you know and
you know he was
everybody you know he's
the most popular kid in the class you
know and
what happened happened you know when i
got pregnant and um i did the best that
i could you know i was um on my own at
17 with him and i had absolutely no
direction and
you know i went from being in high
school one minute to you know also now
i've got to pay rent and there's
doctor's bills and insurance and and and
all sorts of stuff food and
you know a baby that i'm trying to raise
and i'm just a kid myself you know um
and
you know i did the best i could i lived
we i was able to support him for the
first four years of his life and uh
after that um
my
roo we got evicted uh for non-payment of
the rent for one reason or another and i
sent him to live with his father
because he lived with his parents and
his parents i knew would take care of my
son
um
you know and and that was
one
it was
excuse me
that was really difficult
because
when i got pregnant
thanks
i never really wanted kids
because i didn't want to put them
through
what i had already been through
and i
but when i thought i was pregnant like i
did the right thing you know
but it was i just i wanted to be there
if i you know for him the way my parents
weren't for me
but i did the best that i could with
what i had you know and i i was there
like i i weekends and
you know picked them up from school one
night a week you know did homework and
all that stuff and
you know i did the best that i could and
then
in october of 2005
i found my best friend's body
three weeks after she had been killed
and uh i was held hostage by
the person who had killed her
for an hour and a half before the police
showed up
and uh
he uh
said that she had killed herself but it
was clear that she
she didn't and uh
but he was uh in a state of psychosis
and i knew
you know just by the look in his eye
when he
because there was a girl that came with
me
she um
she was uh their
coke dealer's girlfriend and uh
she had been
selling him cocaine for three weeks and
apparently he had been cooking it up and
smoking it up you know
while the while my my best friend's body
is rotting in the house and
pretending like nothing's wrong
uh it was crazy but i broke in there
with her and um she helped me break in
and
um
[Music]
you know uh
he sent her a way to go get some some
cocaine because he wanted to get high
and but he had me you know had already
grabbed me by the arm and pulled me down
on the couch uh
and uh
you know said well you stay here that
way i know you know you know you're my
collateral so i sat there you know it
was an l-shaped couch like this so we're
sitting here and my friend's body's
right here
wrapped in a blanket you know
you know i i just told him that we would
go in the morning and and i would help
him you know i would say i believe him
and you know i played him
i told him anything he wanted to hear
you know because i knew my life was on
the line
you know
but there was finally a knock on the
door an hour and a half later and
it was the police and uh
at first
sergeant tybert walked in and
he's like
you know i'm from a close-knit town like
so everybody knows everybody you know
what i mean and he's like what are you
doing holly because i called them first
to do a welfare check on her
and they said that they had been there
earlier to arrest her for not showing up
for a court date and but there was a
note on the door saying that they were
away and that uh somebody was taking
care of the cat i said yeah but all the
lights are on the keys are there i said
and there's a like a foul odor like
nobody's heard from her dude like you
couldn't put that together yourself
you know and and he said he wouldn't
help me so i broke into the house myself
like because i knew something was wrong
and uh
you know at first he he saw the broken
glass on the kitchen floor and he's like
you know he's like put your hands behind
your back and i was like excuse me
i was like you might want to go handle
the situation you know in the living
room
and uh and goes well what happened and i
said
you know wendy's dead
and she's been dead
for quite some time well
where's her boyfriend john mackenzie in
it when she he's on the couch and he
said well they're both dead i was like
i was like no man like no she's dead he
killed her and he's been in here quite
some time like you know you want to go
handle situation do you want me to put
the cuffs on him you know
and uh
he's like well you know he's like
show me i said you go you're the one
with a weapon you know i'm done my job's
done
and uh i just i'll never forget the look
because he thought that
you know when there was a knock on the
door he thought that it was you know
tracy with the drugs and he gave me 300
and said here grab the drugs and send
them away
and so
you know he thought that he's like so
did you get the drugs and
not realizing that it wasn't even me at
first it was sergeant tiber and then me
and then i mean if looks could kill like
when he realized what i had done that i
completely played him like he lunged at
me and he told me that i would pay for
what i had done
you know and uh
i told him that i wasn't afraid of him
you know
and that those
i
won't i wouldn't sleep until i made sure
that he'd been behind bars for the rest
of his life and he is
i testified and he pleaded
guilty to second-degree murder he just
happened to
just had his uh parole hearing
and uh i couldn't they weren't allowing
people in because of covert and all that
stuff um
but i wrote a strongly worded letter
because his daughter actually contacted
me after almost 20 years
he said holly if he gets out he's like
you're the only one that i know that can
stand up to him
if he gets out our lives are finally
somewhat normal now if he gets out i'm
afraid he's going to take all that all
away
she's like please can you do what you
can to make sure he stays there
and that was his daughter you know and
i um i wrote a letter it's the to the
d.a and and they they read it at his
parole hearing
and uh
he was he was denied parole
and spend the rest of his life behind
bars
you know and
i had always talked to wendy about
uh we always had this dream about moving
off away from the city where we're from
because it's a
gloucester is like a
it's a big fishing town it's america's
oldest seaport and you know it's a big
drinking town and
you know what i mean the biggest thing
we got going is gordon's fishing fishing
plant you know what i mean like working
gonna fire later overnight like and it's
just not we wanted something bigger you
know and uh
i promised there i was talk to her about
going to the military and
she always said that i'd be good at it
so at
25 years old i um
i joined the military and i graduated
first in my class
really yeah
so um and i i
obtained the rank of sergeant in
two and a half years
and i was deployed to iraq in 2009
and uh
i served for 11 months over there and i
was injured
[Music]
we were at a checkpoint
i was in the 10th mountain division
from uh fort drum new york um an mp unit
um because my job over there was uh
i mean i did a lot of admin stuff but i
also was operation so like um
you know i was with a um
water purification unit because i was my
main mos
um but i also acted as their uh
you know combat medic over there as well
and
um
say like the water site needed like
chlorine or something like that or we
needed ammo it's my job to find out uh
what company was leaving my bait my fob
and going to the next fob and i'd have
to jump on you know their mission and go
with them and get to that fob and bring
everything back you know so i did that
for about 11 months and i was pulling
weird a checkpoint and we were ambushed
by small arms and uh mortar rounds
rock-a-pearl grenades and
i was uh
pretty badly injured and i spent a year
and a half
in uh the dwight d eisenhower hospital
in
fort gordon georgia augusta georgia
uh recovering from my injuries and the
army
you know permanently retired me
medically retired me for my injuries
sustained overseas
um
[Music]
you know i was uh you know and
but they had that's kind of where uh
my addiction to fentanyl
uh got started because they had me on
120 milligrams of oxycontin for two
years and cut me off cold turkey i
didn't even know you could get dope sick
i didn't know what dopestick was i mean
i did for my dad a little bit but not
i didn't know you could get doset from
pills like i didn't do drugs i tried to
do everything the opposite you know so i
wouldn't have to go through or put my
son through what
i had gone through with my parents
growing up you know
um
you know and it's it kind of you know
now it's weird because in the end i
worked so hard
you know uh
trying to go the opposite direction i
ended up exactly where
like i feel like exactly where my
parents were you know
which is
you know i don't know
it bothers me
you know
um
my son
has also had issues with drugs
um
you know i put him in re got him into
rehab the first time
i was able to catch it and
um
you know he's doing really good right
now he's not he's
fishing he does a lobster he works on a
lobster boat
in a in rockport massachusetts he's
doing really good he's on suboxone and
he's doing really good for himself and
i'm really proud of him
you know and with covert and everything
i haven't been home in a few years but
i mean honest
you know
the last time i went home it wasn't
really good i was dope sick for the
first three days and i think everybody
kind of knew it and everybody was kind
of sick of my [ __ ] and
it showed because nobody really
i mean they wanted to see me but
you know i didn't really get to see
anybody and
you know i was so ashamed of myself
today you're living where uh today i
live
in los angeles i moved out here after my
husband died well
he died of an overdose
we uh we were on heroin together back
home in massachusetts and well actually
we lived in maine and
we got clean we had 10 and a half months
clean and
i was really trying to make it work and
i had was
had my son living with me i was trying
to make stuff work and
uh he relapsed
and uh
you know i was like after everything i'd
already been through in my life and and
i was actually you know
tolling the line and doing the right
thing and clean and all that and then
like i
got cleaned and have to deal with that
kicking the balls you know like
i was like [ __ ] you
you know
thank you and uh
i um you know and at the same time like
everything with my son like he needed to
go into rehab like everything just
catapulted all at once and i just
i
you know i made sure my son was okay and
that he he was healthy and everything
and you know i waited a couple years i
moved out here to kind of start over you
know i needed maybe a fresh start or
something you know
but it's been i've been out here for
like eight years now
and
it's scary because i feel like
those eight years are just a blur like
i've done nothing but get high i'm out
in the streets and
you know every day i try and make a
dollar just so i can you know be well
and function you know how are you
supporting yourself uh
right now i i do um
well
i i boost uh
which means i go into stores and i steal
[ __ ] and i sell it
you know to make money so i don't have
to you know um
you know i
you know because i i can't i've thought
about selling my body but i i can't i
just can't bring myself to do it
you know but i've been to jail i've been
arrested for boosting and i've had a cop
caught a couple of cases for it you know
and uh
you know jail's no fun
jail is no fun
i miss my grandmother's funeral because
i was in jail
for boosting
um
and you you sleep where you have a tent
or
no i just sleep on the street
you know sometimes like i'll make enough
money for a room but
you know um
[Music]
unfortunately like i make money like the
drugs come first because i can't
function without it
you know so if i make enough money for
it to get you know be well and eat and
that's that's what happens and i don't
mind sleeping in the cold
that's not true
your typical day looks like what you
wake up and i wake up you know i i get
ready like i'm usually dressed a little
bit better but uh it's been a rough
couple of days um
but i get up i get i get dressed like i
dress um you have to play the part so to
speak like you know i put makeup on and
do my hair maybe a business suit or
something like that i put on and i go
into stores and i grab a duffel bag off
the shelf and i
throw items in
you know and and i you know
hope to god that you know you know
tackle me on the way out the door
um
but you know i mean i'll fill carts up
to the rim and and grab a receipt out of
the trash and walk out with a cart you
know like because i'm not gonna go i'm
not gonna be sick that's one thing i'm
not gonna do like i just
i've been sick and and i just that's i
refuse
i'm just not i'm not gonna do it
you know i can't function i just
you know and i was on heroin first
before i got on fentanyl and i only got
on fentanyl because i couldn't find any
good heroin around you know
and i was i kind of
tired of shooting up too you know i
haven't shot up in over three years
you know but the fentanyl man that thing
damn
like kicking from that is no joke like
it's no joke off heroin either but i
mean at least then i could tolerate that
you know what i mean
this like i can't even i can't you just
i mean within hours you're throwing up
your diarrhea like you can't move
i refuse to i refuse to be like that
you know
but
at the same time it's like taking my
whole life like i haven't been home i
mean covered you know kind of over the
last year and a half would kind of put
the kibosh on that but
i've been home because i i can't take
time off from you know doing what i do
every day like you know and i'm sure i'm
not gonna risk smuggling on a plane to
fly home with it
you know like [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
um
you know
but i mean christmas just passed and
like my birthday was uh new year's eve
and you know
i slept on a sidewalk by myself
you know
but
you know i don't know hear your ups and
downs and i guess
do you feel helpless against your
addiction
yeah i do
you know because i've been clean before
and
you know it
nothing's ever the same
you know like you don't have the same
drive you don't have the same anything
like you know
just getting up out of bed is a chore
you know like you don't look forward to
anything like nothing's the same
so what am i supposed to do like do i
get clean and like you know just fake it
and be miserable and just eventually
relapse and
put everybody through everything again
or do i just maintain and figure out a
way try and figure out a way a balance
somehow
you know whatever that balance is you
know
but then again like eight years have
gone by and i still haven't found that
balance so what do i do
do you think if you wrote it out for
that that
uncomfortable
feeling for six months or a year or
whatever maybe your brain chemistry
might
get back to what normal was and
maybe i mean i had i had ten and a half
months you did you know yeah i did i had
ten and a half months and was it still
difficult
yeah
not as difficult though
but it's just nothing's the same
[Music]
but i mean i don't know i guess you're
right i mean i never i never got over a
year people say like if you can get
through the first year you'll be all
right
yeah because what you're doing by taking
these drugs is screwing around with your
your brain chemistry your dopamine and
all these things and
if you
somehow muscled through
a certain period of time i don't know if
it's a year or six months or
three years i don't know but some period
of time you would think it would your
brain would come back and start
producing these chemicals on their own
yeah i mean
it's just it's hard no it's got to be
you know it's terribly hard
it's like jesus christ you know like
i've done my whole life is fight
you know that's all i know how to do is
fight and survive fight and survive i
fight and survive it's got to be
depressing as well
yeah i'm tired
i'm tired
you know i
i mean i guess nobody ever asked for
addiction you know like i just wish that
you know when i was injured i wish that
they had paid more attention or given me
more knowledge on
you know
on addiction in in the pills they were
giving me i was on 13 different
medications
thirteen i went from being on zero not
even taking a tylenol for a headache to
thirteen heavy duty like valium xanax
but you know i mean oxycontin percocet
i mean you name it i was on it i mean
that's crazy
and then they just they give you a flag
and a pin a pat on the back a boot in
the ass and say good job soldier
the [ __ ]
you know that really made me bitter
you know because
you know those of us that have
experienced like real combat like
in order to survive it you have to give
up a part of yourself that you never get
back
and
you know for the most part we you know
accept that that that that part of us
will never come back
i just i guess i didn't it wasn't
the fact that i was so expendable
and it was just another number
you know
[Music]
like didn't they understand like what
kind of
sacrifices i had to make out there you
know
well
the parts of myself that
i had to let go of out there in order to
you know to get the mission done and to
come home
you know wasn't that worth
something you know i felt like to them
it was oh well
you know
and that really that really stuck with
me
that really made me really bitter
do you regret enlisting them
no
no i um
[Music]
today's army is a lot different i thank
god i was like
part of the last graduating class of old
school you know like you know you're
raised like you know when i qualified
with my m16 for the first time like you
know they punched me in my chest with
the you know you get the
with your um
your metal but they don't put the the
backings on and they punch it and that's
part of your initiation like i was part
of the last class that got to do that
you know it was part of the hard
chargers that like
you know like the military was something
like we're the power most powerful force
in the world you know what i mean like
we took pride in what we did and we were
strong we had backbone
what i see in today's military man
it's just
oh yeah
it makes me
sad what's going to happen when she hits
the fan
they're going to look to us people that
they discarded you know and consider it
labeled us as monsters or unstable or
whatever
they're going to want to come to us to
help fix to fix the issue
you know
but i was really good at what i did
you know i finally found something that
i was good at that i could be
proud of
you know that i didn't
[ __ ] up totally you know
what are you afraid of no
i'm afraid of no
i'm afraid of
i'm afraid of
waking up 10 years from now and
pushing a cart on the street full of
trash like i see you know a lot of these
older women like
i just don't think my story ends here
i just don't know how to get out of it
and i'm more afraid of them
like time's running out
you know
i've already been out here eight years
like
you know
like i know this stuff is real dangerous
too you know
i've never heard or anything like that
no not
once um
[Music]
but that's not to say you know
i know i gamble every time like i i dose
or whatever i mean i smoke it i don't i
don't shoot i know it never happened i
never will
i just feel like
it just sucks because
i'm tired of
trying to [ __ ] fight
him just feel like i never really got a
break in life you know
[ __ ] like
and i i i just i gotta make a choice
either
i i fight and i get out of this
situation or it's gonna swallow me
and i'm more afraid of that i've run out
of time
and i'm just not ready to make that
choice yet
but i got a son at home who's 23 who's
he's a really good kid
you know
i want to be able to be there for him
you know how am i supposed to be there
for him when i'm out here getting high
and he's doing doing the right thing
like
you know
that sucks
but
i've got to figure something out because
i don't want to
like i guess my worst fear would be for
him
to succumb to his addictions
and end up
out on the street like me you know
i don't think i'd ever forgive myself
for that
um
[Music]
i just don't know how to make my way
back there i guess i've just been kind
of pulling around lost
i just don't know how to make my way
back i'm you know
i don't know if i can
that's not true i know i can i just
i'm just tired
you know
all right holly thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah
i wish you lots of luck getting back
thanks
you